every time I tell you how lazy Donald
Trump is and how little work he's doing
how long he's spending at his golf clubs
and on the golf course how long he is
spending watching TV and how he never
reads it's sort of a mixed bag because
on the one hand obviously I don't want a
lazy piece of crap president I want
somebody who does things and reads
things and is informed and studies
issues deeply something that I just have
seen no evidence Donald Trump is
actually capable of on the other hand
though there is this sense in which like
the less Trump does maybe the better off
we are but according to a new report
Donald Trump has receded even further
into this never-ending sight cycle or
circle of watching Fox News and eating
and tweeting because as of yesterday
morning Donald Trump has had nothing
nothing on his schedule all week other
than lunch with Mike Pence one day and
his presidential daily briefing which
for most presidents is an extensive
meeting with our intelligence community
after having read a bunch of stuff on
paper and studied other issues related
to it the night before for Trump the PDB
the presidential daily briefing has been
reduced to a single page mostly pictures
and charts and graphs with a couple of
bullet points that's all that Donald
Trump has had on his schedule and
reportedly that PDB did not go well
yesterday morning Trump reportedly
reaming out dan coates the Director of
National Intelligence so what else is
Trump doing is Trump spending so much
time on the phone negotiating great
deals that he needs his schedule to be
completely clear is he involved in more
secret talks with Vladimir Putin of
which there are going to be no records
whatsoever is he about ready to get
Mexico to pay for the wall and it's
taking up time is he preparing for Black
History Month which starts on February
1st somehow I don't think so
or is he just lazy and doing nothing and
worried about the storm cloud of
criminality that is closer and closer to
completely enveloping him now you would
be completely appropriate if you said
we'll hold on David
what did a day out of President Obama's
schedule look like just to compare very
good question I took a look I picked the
random day out of President Obama's
schedule and what you'll realize is that
President Obama had a very different
schedule than Trump for example at 9:30
a.m. this was by the way after President
Obama would get up and either exercise
or read neither activity one that Donald
Trump partakes in 9:30 a.m. president
and vice president received the
presidential daily briefing 10:00 a.m.
income the senior advisors to the
president 10:30 a.m. president goes
directly into a cabinet meeting 12:15
the president and vice president meet
for lunch privately at 1:30 the
president meets with members of the
Technology CEO council at 4:30 the
president and vice president have a
meeting with Secretary of Defense gates
even though they already had the
presidential daily briefing at first
9:30 in the morning
6:20 p.m. the president delivers remarks
on the situation in Egypt and then of
course we know that President Obama
would then go to the residence and read
up documents briefings books nonfiction
fiction so there is a very clear
difference here Pat the only question is
are we better off the less Trump does ah
that's a good question I've never been
able to get a conclusive answer on that
and I would just say that being lazy
every now and then that's all well and
good it's nice to veg out like I'm going
on vacation next week for example and
I'm looking forward to it but I'm not
the president I think when you decide to
run for president and you get elected
you have to be able to invest that four
year period and work as hard as you can
only take a little bit of time off here
and there and even then you're getting
working vacations you have to be able to
be committed to the job and Trump just
isn't yeah and there's a couple of other
elements here as well which is that this
didn't just sneak up on Trump Trump
actually said I'm gonna be so busy I'm
not going to be leaving the White House
there's not going to be any golfing or
anything like that he said setting
records for how much he golf's and if we
look at Trump's tweets this week they're
seeming like kind of extra flaccid and
weak and I think that there may be
something just more generally going on
with him check out this example Trump
tweeted yesterday
if the committee of Republicans and
Democrats now meeting on border security
is not discussing or contemplating a
wall or physical barrier they are
wasting their time yeah all right okay
you've said that before and it's pretty
boring and it doesn't really seem to
have any power behind it now that you
completely lost the shutdown so my
question to the audience is as follows
should we be critical of this lazy
impostor president or should we be glad
that he's not actually doing things
since what he does is bad for the
country and for the world a lot of
people wrote to me saying yeah the less
involved Trump is the better off
everyone is but I don't think it's that
simple and the reason why is Trump told
us he was going to hire the best people
obviously that hasn't happened even when
Trump is just watching Fox and Friends
those horrible cabinet members and
staffers are still out there damaging
the world it's really a double-edged
sword and I could sort of see it from
both sides but what we do know for sure
is the guy's barely doing a damn thing
hey guys if you have a dog or a cat at
home or if you're looking for the
perfect gift for somebody in your life
who has a dog or a cat check out today's
sponsor pet box a subscription box where
you can get 50% off of your first box
when you click the link under this video
and use the coupon code Pakman when you
sign up for pet box you get an awesome
selection of premium toys all natural
treats for your dog or cat delivered to
your doorstep every month and each month
the box is totally different it's
actually very affordable when you sign
up for the dog box you tell them what
size dog you have and you get a monthly
variety of chew toys rawhides bags of
dog treats and a whole bunch of other
cool items catered to the size of your
dog the cat box comes with a ton of
different stuff every month like catnip
toys snacks things for them to scratch
on and almost everything that comes in
each box is made by small family-owned
businesses I just got the dog box for my
dad's in
this lab named Nemo who if you follow me
on Instagram you're probably familiar
with got a bunch of cool stuff including
pterodactyl treats and a true hide thing
obviously I don't know what all these
things are called and a toy which I know
my dad is just gonna love that noise and
the best thing about pet box is that
they give 10% of the proceeds to a
non-profit called tender loving canines
which helps provide service dogs to
people with autism and to vets with PTSD
so part of your purchase goes to a
really good cause and like I said you
can get half off your first box when you
click the link under this video and use
the coupon code Pakman that's PA que ma
n